so we have finally found an agreement
it was a long and winding road but
we have got a good deal to show for it
it is fair it is a balanced deal
and it is the right and responsible
thing to do for both sides
first of all competition in our single
market
will be fair and remain so
the eu rules and standards will be
respected
we have effective tools to react
if fair competition is distorted and
impacts our trade secondly
we will continue cooperating with the uk
in all areas of mutual interest
for example in the field of climate
change
energy security and transport
together we still achieve more than we
do apart
and thirdly we have secured five and a
half
years of full predictability for our
fishing communities
and strong tools to incentivize
to remain so of course
this whole debate has always been about
sovereignty
but we should cut through the sound
bites and ask ourselves
what sovereignty actually means in the
21st century
for me it is about being able
to seamlessly do work travel study
and do business in 27 countries
it is about pooling our strength and
speaking together
in a world full of great powers
and in a time of crisis it is about
pulling each other up instead of trying
to get back to your feet alone
and the european union shows how this
works in practice and no deal in the
world
can change reality or gravity in today's
economy
and today's world we are one of the
giants